Hi, I'm Erik Voss, and now that Game of
Thrones season 7 is coming, a ton of you
guys have been hitting me up asking
about this new theory about who will
be revealed as the real hero of Westeros
when the series ends. And yes, I know I'm
wearing glasses, I'm having issues with
contacts, also I want to look smarter for
this video. Anyway, in this video I'm
going to get into some potential
spoilers for season seven of Game of
Thrones, but really these are all just
theories and predictions based on stuff
that has already come up on the show and
in the book so far. Okay, if you've been
following the show and the Books closely,
you're probably familiar with the
prophecy of Azor Ahai, also sometimes
referred to as the prince that was
promised. Now, I'm going to go into the
back story on this prophecy, but if you
feel like you already know it pretty
well and just want to get right to the
theory, you can skip to this time. So, in
George RR Martin's universe, the prince
that was promised was an ancient
prophesied leader who will deliver the
world from darkness. According to legend,
he will be born amidst smoke and salt
under a bleeding star and he will have a
song, the Song of Ice and Fire.
Now, obviously there's a lot of
metaphorical language here and a lot of
people over the years have interpreted
this differently. Naturally, pretty much
everyone tries to exploit it for power.
So one of the characters believed to be
the princess promise was Stannis
Baratheon. In the eyes of Lady Melisandre,
he was actually considered the second
coming of Azor Ahai. Now, Azor Ahai
is an ancient legendary hero to the
followers of the Lord of Light (Relor.) Azor Ahai wielded a fiery sword called
light bringer, and people of this religion
believe Azor Ahai will be reborn as a
new person with his own fiery sword to
defeat the darkness brought on by the
others - the White Walkers.
So, really Azure Ahai reborn and the
prince that was promised are kind of terms
that are just used interchangeably.
Nowadays, people believe that they point
to the same prophetic figure. Now,
Melisandre assumed that Stannis was Azor Ahai reborn, interpreting the red
comet that appeared in the sky in
season 2 to be the bleeding star. But,
considering the way things ended for
Stannis, that's obviously not the case.
Now there was another character who
arrived, so to speak, under this bleeding
star around the same time, Daenerys
Targaryen. The miraculous birth of her
dragons at the end of season 1 was a key
symbolic rebirth
for her character taking place amid
smoke and I guess salt? Maybe in that
salty desert sand, or the tears she wept
for Khal Drogo? Again guys, this is all
metaphorical, but the other popular
candidate for Azor Ahai reborn is Jon
Snow. This guy freakin' resurrected from
the dead with the help of Melisandre in
her prayers to the Lord of Light, and
really more than anyone else in the show,
Jon seems to be the most heroic leader
against the White Walkers. But long
before these two people, many believed
that the prince that was promised was
Rhaegar Targaryen, including Rhaegar
himself. He was known to be a singer and
an amazing swordsman, and in book three,
Daenerys learned that her late brother
found something in a scroll and decided
that he must become a warrior. I'm
guessing it was this prophecy. Also, in
the books, in Daenerys's vision she
sees her brother holding the baby Aegon
Targaryen, cryptically saying he is the
prince that was promised, and his is a
Song of Ice and Fire.
Now, of course that baby was horribly
murdered by the Mountain, Gregor Clegane, in
the sack of King's Landing, so that
wasn't the case, but we also know that
Rhaegar had another baby, Jon Snow, so
maybe this is more evidence that Jon is
the prince that was promised. Anyway,
there are also just a ton of alternate
theories that Azor Ahai could be someone
else like Bran, Arya, Tyrion, Samwell
Tarly... just kidding, no one thinks it's him.
But, the newest theory out there is that
Azor Ahai reborn is Jaime Lannister, the
Kingslayer, the villainous incestuous
twin brother turned more redemptive... but
still kind of incestuous hero. And
here's why this guy could end up saving
all of Westeros by the end of the series:
So, according to legend, Azor Ahai created
his flaming sword, Lightbringer, in a
three-step forging process. And again, all
these details are really meant to be
metaphor that we can interpret and apply
to other people who have similar
parallel journeys. So first, Azor Ahai
forged for 30 days and 30 nights and
then he tempered the sword in water, but
the sword broke, so the second time he
spent 50 days and 50 nights and tempered
it by plunging it into the heart of a
lion... lie-on, but again the steel
shattered and the third time he spent
100 days and 100 nights,
and he called in his wife, Nissa
Nissa, and drove the sword into her heart
and her soul merged with the steel to
create Lightbringer. And if you think
about it, these three crucial steps
correspond to Jaime's character arc,
transitioning him from the detestable
Kingslayer to the more heroic Jaime
Lannister. So one of the first big
character moments for Jaime, both in the
books and in the show, was right after he
lost his hand. Remember he took a bath
with Brienne and breaks down emotionally
as well as physically, revealing his side
of the story that led to his famous
nickname of Kingslayer. So, just like when
Azor Ahai tempered his first sword in
water it shattered, when Jamie goes into
the water he breaks as well. Pay close
attention to how this confession scene
ends: "The Kingslayer!
Jaime. My name's Jaime."
So this is Jamie's rebirth, breaking
out of this Kingslayer shell to become
a more morally complex hero. Okay, so
another key step for Jaime's growth as a
character, was the breaking apart of the
Lannister family structure. So throughout
season 4, Jaime rapidly loses his son
Joffrey, followed by his father Tywin,
which results in the exile of his
brother Tyrion. In fact, it was Jaime's
decision to defy his father and free
Tyrion that led to Tyrion killing Tywin
by firing an arrow directly into his
heart. Of course, Tywin was the patriarch
of the Lannisters whose sigil is the
lion. And as Cersei coldly told Jaime at
Tywin's funeral, it was Jaime's actions
that killed their daddy lion.  "Tyrion may be a monster but at least he killed our father on purpose.
You killed him by mistake, with stupidity." So, by breaking away from this pride of
lions, Jaime parallels the second step of
Azor Ahai's forging, plunging the sword
into the heart of the lion. And that
brings us to the final step: Azor Ahai's
sacrifice of his wife and companion Nissa Nissa, and here's where
things get interesting. So, besides Azor Ahai and the prince
that was promised, another key prophecy
in Game of Thrones was the one that
Cersei received as a young girl from the
wood witch, who's Maggie the frog in the
books. So, even though this doesn't happen
in the show, in the books, Cersei is also
told that she will die by the hand of
her valonqar, and that's the
Valyrian word for younger brother. Now,
Cersei has always interpreted that
younger brother to be Tyrion, which is
one of the reasons she's always been so
suspicious of him. Remember in season 2,
Tyrion threatens her with this line:
"The day would come when you think you're safe and happy, and your joy will turn to
ashes in your mouth." And that threat has
always haunted her, but now it appears
that Valonqar could be a different
younger brother - her twin brother, Jaime
Lannister, who was born a few minutes
after her. So remember, Cersei just blew
up a huge piece of King's Landing using
the same jars of wildfire that the Mad
King stored beneath the city. The same
war crime that Jaime slew that King to
prevent. So now that Cersei has become a
bit of a mad queen, it's possible that
Jaime might repeat history, fulfilling
his destiny both as the valonqar and
Azor Ahai, sacrificing his longtime
companion, to create light bringer. Now,
what would this fiery sword look like? So
in my breakdown of the season 7 trailer,
I talked about how Jaime's new sword,
widow's wail, was one of the twin
Valyrian steel swords that Tywin melted
down from the Stark sword, Ice. And yeah,
maybe the moment that Jaime drives this
sword into Cersei's heart, it'll burst
into flames. And maybe, at the same time,
Brienne's sword Oathkeeper will also burst
into flames, since they were forged from
the same steel, ice. A song of ice on fire.
But, I think that there's another equally
awesome way this could go. Also, in that
season 7 breakdown I pointed out how in
that shot of the large floor map in the
red keep, Cersei is standing on the neck
of Westeros, but what I didn't point out
is that Jaime is standing right beside
the east coast of Westeros, and these
narrow peninsulas are called the fingers.
So this shot could be foreshadowing
Jaime using his literal fingers to
strangle Cersei around her neck. But then
again, remember that threat from Tyrion
"And your joy will turn to ashes in
your mouth." So it could be that light
bringer doesn't refer to a literal sword,
but Jamie's golden hand, bursting into
flames as he chokes Cersei, causing
literal ashes to form in her mouth. So
yeah, it's a pretty gruesome,
but pretty epic and poetically justified
way for Cersei to die,
considering the masses she burned at the
end of last season. And yeah, I know this
sounds crazy, but when you look back,
this visual has been foreshadowed
throughout the series. So first in book 3, right after Jamie's
hand is cut off, there's this passage: "His
hand burned, and his fingers twisting in
the flames, the fingers can no longer had."
Also in the show, in that key moment I
talked about when Jamie freed Tyrion
Jamie holds a fiery torch, and it flashes
in front of the camera. And sure, that one
could be stretching, but there was also
this pivotal moment in the first episode,
when Bran caught Jaime and Cersei in
the act and Jaime's hand is around
Cersei's throat, so Jaime's iconic line of
"the things I do for love" could come full circle later, when he's now turned on Cersei.
And speaking of Bran, in season four there's an interesting scene where Bran, Meera
and Jojen Reed speculate on their
journey, specifically how it would end.
"This isn't the end. How... will we know the end?
You'll know."
So remember, Jojen Reed would dream
visions of the future, and maybe this is
Jojen's way of saying that they'll know
it's the end when Azor Ahai returns to
vanquish the White Walkers with his
light bringer being a hand of fire. Also,
here's a fun detail that could connect
Jamie to the Lord of Light prophecy: the
Valyrian words for Lord and light - Aeskio and Onos, are weirdly similar to Aeskion
and Ondos, which translates to
gold hand. So it could be that over
thousands of years, this prophecy just
got lost in translation, and the Lord of
light's champion was always destined to
be the man with the golden hand. Now, just
to be clear I still think Game of Thrones
seems way more focused on Jon and
Daenerys as the heroes of the story. Like,
the two of them have both experienced
classic hero's journeys: highborn
children in exile traveling to the far
corners of the world, coming back from
death to become leaders of men. But, I
would argue that Jamie has experienced
the most personal growth. Remember, we
hated this guy in that first episode. But
then over time, he completely transformed
into a hero that we kind of like. But,
what are your thoughts? Does Jamie
being Azor Ahai reborn sound like a
satisfying conclusion for this whole
series? Or does that idea take away
significance from other characters? Like,
guys, that would mean the prince that was
promised can't be Sam. I know, hearts are
breaking. But do you think that there's
any other unexpected character that you
predict will be revealed as Azor Ahai
reborn? Or do you think the show can get
away with not even resolving this mystery
at all. I'm curious to hear any theories that
you have. Let me know down in the
comments, and again, make sure to check
out my season 7 trailer breakdown for
more predictions and missable clues
about this new season. And if you like
this video, please hit like and subscribe
to new rockstars, and if you really like
us you can contribute to us on patreon.
Thank you so much to all of our current
patrons, especially Matthew Salvas. You can
hit me up on Twitter (@eavoss) with any
thoughts you have about Game of
Thrones season 7, or follow new rock
stars on Twitter (@newrockstars) for
updates on our videos. Ok, thanks for
watching. Bye.